ailleurs dans le monde le maroc fait
face à une recrudescence des
contaminations coronavirus le pays tente
d'accélérer sa campagne de vaccination
les autorités ont pris de nouvelles
mesures restrictives s'appliquant sur
l'ensemble du territoire elle certaines
villes ont même été placés en
confinement total elles les précisions
de notre correspondant au maghreb
assembly ce nouveau pic de contamination
coronavirus dans le royaume du maroc un
épisode épidémique aussi importante que
lors de la première vague en novembre
2020 le pays enregistre actuellement
5000 nouveaux cas quotidiens pour y
faire face le gouvernement a annoncé de
nouvelles mesures et les ville
touristique d'agadir casablanca ou
encore marrakech sont confinés tandis
que le couvre-feu passe de 23h à 5h du
matin sur l'ensemble du territoire
marocain cafés et restaurants doivent
fermer leurs portes à 21h alors que les
rassemblements de plus de 25 personnes
sont interdits mariages fêtes événements
culturels sont pour le moment
interrompues et les lieux accueillant du
public voient leur capacité d'accueil
est réduite à 50% les déplacements entre
les différentes régions sont interdits
ainsi que l'accès aux villes confiné
sauf pour les marocains disposant d'un
passeport vaccinale les autorités
marocaines encouragent leurs populations
à privilégier le télétravail autres
mesures difficiles en pleine saison
estivale les hôtels et autres
établissements touristiques ne doivent
pas dépasser 75 % de leur capacité
d'accueil le royaume qui a pour ambition
de produire localement le vaccin chinois
de sinopharm poursuit sa campagne de
vaccination pour faire face au corona
virus à ce jour 24 millions de doses du
sérum astrazeneca et sinopharm ont été
administrées dans l'ensemble du pays